[Music]
congratulations on your movie in this
film it's such a powerful film and even
bigger Congrats on your engagement let's
see that ring girl shall I said he did
good he did good
how long did you keep this a secret this
engagement wasn't keeping it a secret
just didn't you know my sister Tamar
said something before it was really out
so everything's good I'm excited and
then you've come a long way from unbreak
my heart yeah how did you know that
Birdman was the one well you know he and
I've been friends for a really long time
for like 17 years and it just grew from
friendship to more than that so you got
to keep your friends close you never
know what could happen we just saw
trailer for your a Braxton Family Values
it seems like you're in the process of
wedding planning
what are on your top three wish list for
your wedding the cake is important
the groom's cake is important and the
dress and I'm over 40 so you have to be
I'm particular about the dress over 40
it's kind of like an episode of Sex in
the City the last final bride of
authority so I have to find something
that's appropriate but sexy at the same
time et spoke with Tony at the Los
Angeles premiere of the forgiven she
wrote multiple songs for the film I
think the film is brilliant I loved when
I fell in love with the film I wrote
this beautiful song to it but to work
with mr. force whatever in any way I can
Eric banner of course he's beautiful
delicious eye candy I am delighted that
they chose me to be the person to
narrate the song through music
[Music]